apple has been trying to make the ipad
pro a laptop replacement for years
and with the new magic keyboard i can
finally admit
that they've achieved their goal from
the very first time
i used the trackpad in the phenomenal
keyboard
i could tell that apple has created
something truly special
the only issue is that it's very
expensive
with a starting price of 300 which is
about the same price as a brand new ipad
and that's where logitech's new folio
touch keyboard case comes in
it basically packs a lot of the same
features as the magic keyboard
but for almost half the price a hundred
and sixty dollars instead of 300
and there are actually a few ways that
the folio touch
straight up beats the magic keyboard
which i'll get into in just a moment
now on the other hand i discovered some
issues with it that might lead to some
people
investing some extra cash and buying
apple's keyboard case instead
but before we dig into all of that i
want to go through all the features that
are making me
recommend this keyboard case instead of
all the other cheap bluetooth keyboards
you can find on amazon
the number one feature of the folio
touch is that it comes with a built-in
trackpad
which fully takes advantage of apple's
new cursor support
for the ipad and when i say fully i mean
every single feature in fact it's the
only keyboard case for the 11-inch ipad
pro
that comes with a trackpad that supports
perfectly smooth scrolling
and three-finger gestures even the new
bridge pro plus keyboard case for 200
doesn't get these trackpad features just
like every other bluetooth keyboard out
there
the trackpad experience on the bridge is
just bad
with choppy scrolling and very limited
gesture support
and there are two reasons why the
logitech folio touch
is the only keyboard apart from the
magic keyboard
that gets full trackpad support number
one is that logitech
is working directly with apple to
develop their ipad
accessories so they're the only ones
that have access
to apple's brand new trackpad apis
and number two is that logitech is the
only third-party manufacturer
that has permission from apple to use
the smart connector in their accessories
the smart
connector is basically a unique metal
contact connector
that now comes on every new ipad except
for the ipad mini
and it allows data and even power to be
transferred between
an ipad and an accessory as you can see
on the inside of the folio touch there
are three metal pogo pins
that make contact with the smart
connector on the back side of the ipad
pro
and the beauty of it is that as soon as
you put your ipad pro into the case
the ipad itself powers the keyboard
and the trackpad and it starts working
instantly
there's no connecting using bluetooth
and there's no need
to recharge a bulky battery and to make
it even better
the hardwired smart connection means
that every keystroke happens
instantly and the trackpad gets instant
responsiveness
for navigation swiping and gestures now
when i initially compared the folio
touch to the magic keyboard case a
couple of days ago the trackpad was a
bit glitchy
and there was actually a bit of lag when
smashing the keys as fast as i could
and to my surprise there was still no
lag
on the magic keyboard but thankfully a
firmware update was released
shortly after that video and the lag
situation
has definitely improved and if you're
actually typing
instead of smashing the keys you don't
notice any lag at all
better yet the trackpad has improved as
well
being more responsive than before so if
you're gonna pick up the folio touch
you need to head to the app store
download the logitech
control app and then update the firmware
and i'm happy to say that it also fixed
the keyboard backlighting issue
which now works perfectly fine after the
update
even though i'm using ipad os 14 beta
and it even supports a feature that i
totally didn't expect
on this third party case and that's
automatic backlighting
so basically the keyboard backlighting
turns on by itself
as the room you're in gets darker and it
works like a dream
just like on the magic keyboard now
before i dig deeper into the keyboard
and the trackpad
i want to talk about the case in general
as for the material
you get a fabric-like yet plastic finish
on the exterior
and the inside of the keyboard which
should look great
after many months of use the case itself
fully
wraps around the ipad pro with a hard
plastic shell on the back
and rubber on the sides giving you much
better drop protection
than the magic keyboard the only
downside is that the folio touch is
quite a bit more thick
and it's actually heavier sitting at 646
grams
compared to 601 the top of the case
features a perfect cutout for the apple
pencil
so it can use the wireless charging and
it comes with a flap
that magnetically attaches to the other
side of the case
and protects the pencil while it's
charging and one of our commenters
mentioned that it also has
a little sleeve for the pencil built
into the flap
which basically guarantees that the
apple pencil won't fall off
if you want to be extra safe this is an
excellent solution
and it's much better than going commando
on the magic keyboard
now i want to talk about the stand
because this
is what's going to make or break the
folio touch for a lot of people
there's basically a hard plastic flap on
the back
that works as a stand and what i like
about it is that it gives you a massive
amount of angle adjustability
the main downside is that you need a
little bit of extra room on your desk to
use this
whereas the magic keyboard doesn't
require that and the other downside is
that opening up the folio touch
is a two-step process adjusting the
stand
and then laying down the keyboard
compared to one
oddly satisfying swoop with the magic
keyboard
now to my surprise the folio touch
actually worked pretty well
on my lap and that's because all of the
weight of the ipad pro
is supported by the stand so it won't
tip over
and the keyboard portion itself stayed
put incredibly well
because the hinge that connects it to
the actual case
is made up of a strong piece of fabric
that has a lot of give to it
because of this any movement in my knees
doesn't
translate to the keyboard giving you a
pretty solid
typing experience while on your lap now
let's talk about that hinge
what makes it really special is that
unlike the magic keyboard
it allows you to fold the keyboard
behind the ipad pro
to either use it in media viewing mode
with the stand still in place
or flat on the table for drawing or
taking notes
with the apple pencil and the best part
is that the keyboard is automatically
disabled
even in media viewing mode this can be a
pretty big deal because being able to
fold
the keyboard back means that you can
switch to using the ipad pro
in portrait mode at any time now you can
also do this with a magic keyboard
but you have to take the ipad pro itself
off of the case
which compromises the last bit of drop
protection you were getting with it
but for those of you who do want to
occasionally go commando with your ipad
pro
it's definitely a pain to take it out of
the folio touch case
now let's jump back into the keyboard
the typing experience is pretty decent
although not as nice as with the magic
keyboard but the major advantage
with the folio touch is that you get a
top row
of function keys giving you very
convenient controls
for everything from an escape key
brightness controls
media controls backlighting controls a
spotlight search button
an on-screen keyboard button and a lock
screen button
for some people these function keys
could be the main reason why
you would choose this over the magic
keyboard now let's finish off with
the trackpad it uses a pretty common
diving board design
which means that it's attached at the
top where it's almost
impossible to click but at the bottom
it's incredibly
easy to click so basically it's nowhere
near
as premium feeling as the magic keyboard
which has
a totally unique design which gives you
an even clicking feel
all around the trackpad but on the plus
side it still supports
tap to click so you don't really have to
physically click it very often
and as far as the smoothness of the
trackpad scrolling and swiping is very
smooth
and it completely embarrasses the
functionality
of other bluetooth keyboards like the
bridge pro
plus and the best part is that the folio
touch supports
three finger gestures which take
productivity to a whole new level
so before i wrap up this review and give
you guys my thoughts on the folio touch
i want to quickly go through all of the
ways that the magic keyboard case is
better
the magic keyboard is thinner it's
lighter
it's much more solid it looks and feels
much more premium and modern you get a
very solid hinge
that gives you a totally unique floating
ipad experience
the keys feel better the keyboard has
absolutely zero input lag
the trackpad is excellent with perfect
reliability
responsiveness and ease of clicking and
finally
it has an incredibly useful charging
port built into the hinge
freeing up the ipad pro's port for other
things like connecting storage
accessories
and hooking up to displays and other
devices
and with that i want to mention the five
major ways
that the logitech folio touch is better
than the magic keyboard case
number one is obviously the price being
a hundred and forty dollars
cheaper number two is the protection
since it literally wraps around
the entire ipad pro and the rubber
bumpers
are thick enough to protect it from
decent drops number three is the apple
pencil storage method
being much more practical and safe
number four is the top row of function
keys
which you don't get with the magic
keyboard and number five
is the ability to fold the keyboard
behind the ipad pro
if at least three of these things are
extremely important to you
then i would honestly recommend the
folio touch over the magic keyboard
despite all of the ways that the magic
keyboard is superior
so hopefully this review helped to make
a purchasing decision
and if it did we'll have links to the
best deals on both of these keyboard
cases
down in the description below right next
to the link to our new
premium apple product merch and if you
didn't watch the full comparison yet
you can find it right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you
in the next video
you